[Music]
look at that picture Kurt Russell and
Goldie Hawn it's family christmas came
early
three generations got together for the
premiere of Kurt's new Netflix movie the
Christmas Chronicles look at Kurt rockin
that long hair you can pull it off and
you know even the movie is a bit of a
family affair because Kurt Kringle stars
with his son Oliver five and in person
one night only
Curtis sanon Oliver's the dad of two
kids who help old st. Nick save
Christmas I was very committed to you
know getting the right look at but I
knew that was going to be growing a
beard and we colored my hair which I
still have yeah
I wanted him to look right Kurt Goldy
and the Russell Hudson clan - new momma
Kate and her kids were on the red carpet
Kurt once played a mall Santa Claus for
his son Wyatt because the sand on duty
had left I looked at the car it was a
really good cos I'm really good beard
and Ike was hidden behind it really well
so I didn't think I didn't think why I
would pick up on on me being that Paul
and the kids would be staring staring
and as they get up to me there has it
just too often they look down so there
is this there is this you know it's a
little bright let's get this party
started
when the rustle / Hudson family gets
together for Christmas just like the
movie there's a bit of mayhem
it's truly a grand holiday for us I mean
it is the number one holiday and it's
true tradition and we do not want to
break that tradition and this is real
you know why must think he's drawing me
like that does my butt really look that
big you boy everybody already talking
about Christmas wait a minute we got to
do Thanksgiving
[Music]